- Well, last month you went to Houston
and reported form George Floyd's funeral.
What was the most powerful moment
of that experience for you?
- Well, within a week I was in Houston,
but before that I was in Minneapolis
for the memorial service.
I think the most powerful moment for me
was when Reverend Sharpton
was doing the eulogy
and he said, "Let's pause for
eight minutes and 46 seconds."
And I was outside the church
and I'm seeing this
sea of people out there
and just looking at the faces,
some people were crying,
some people were praying,
some people were just shellshocked.
I think I was in the shellshocked category
of trying to imagine that period of time.
It's a long, long time.
And, of course, it references the time
that the officer's knee
was on George Floyd's neck.
But I think that really moved me.
You've seen the video,
but you see it through a different lens
when you really feel that length of time.
- Yeah, I was gonna say,
sitting there for that long,
it really puts things in perspective
of how long it actually
is, is what you're saying.
But, you know, as a journalist,
what makes Floyd's story different
from others like it that you've covered?
Because unfortunately
there's been a lot of stories
of people dying that should not have died
and/or police brutality
or just any instance that's
kind of in a similar vein.
We hear about so many,
Breonna Taylor, Tamir Rice,
we hear about so many,
so what do you think
made this one different?
- I think because we were
all eye witnesses to it.
You're right, we've
seen many of these cases
and very often ends up
being jumbled dash cam video
or body cam video.
This was a rather steady shot
of a man being suffocated to death.
And there's no equivocating that,
there's no walking around it,
there's no, "Well, maybe it
could've been this or that."
It was what you saw
and when you bear witness
to something that awful,
you can't walk away from
it, you can't discount it,
you can't leave it to other people.
And so I think, you know, when I look out,
and sometimes protesters come
right here by my apartment,
I look out and I see black and white
and Asians and Hispanics, I
see a rainbow of people here,
as human beings who are saying,
"No, that doesn't stand in our society."
So I think his case has just,
it symbolized so many things we've seen,
but it was just so graphic and so awful
and as I said, we're
all eye witnesses to it.
- Yeah, no, I agree with that.
And it's on film.
It's hard to negate that.